are you being serious what's her tone ah
ha ha Marquart does justice require me
she said he should go down for murder
for that what at what you're always
kinda left by voice asleep abyssal and
you sent me some silly videos of some
guys doing some dumb so I'm gonna rape
all right cool
first video let's see is that a real
person it's a trooper that's the stress
that's required me she said he should go
down for murder for that water 20
it's an a no stairs holding me what's it
one more time why don't you just go
round the up like you could jump this Oh
walk that's just stupid
that is just stupid you could have just
gone into someone's flat and just put
the lid well this looks like a pocket or
a 12
someone could at least hold it for him I
mean it's just a donor oh my god
obviously this is something coffee
what you put in his mouth that's quality
our these of you later
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you gonna give me the other world
for this oh my gosh you don't need your
own TV show but that is actually that is
quite tiny that's insatiable
if you fall asleep this is what you
deserve I do this all the time - gonna
show you Wow look at that that's a
masterpiece
alright next one what we got that is
bang out of order I need to watch that
again
what artwork oh my god hope to be honest
with you that was me I wouldn't be happy
I'll get the on tomorrow anymore Tyson
Fury
well next one you know Ethan makes a
name in people how could you not jump
over that just leave it me
[Music]
if that was Hennessey but I'll be like
laughs you know get it before month May
I'm just going to be revealing his
because bottom just enjoying them so
much so I'm excuse me I'm it really I'm
giving you my rating feedback but yet
out just hilarious not something I would
do and that's made to be quite dangerous
you know so I wouldn't actually try that
at home because apparently there's
really can get brain damage and you can
really hurt yourself so do you not copy
these old fellas they're meant to be
sent an example but obviously is doing
big kids don't try not to get home
ironically I've designed a new group and
I've got a new song called men are trash
and I think that is the perfect
soundtrack for all of these men so make
sure you go check it out
thank you for sharing your videos it's
been a pleasure I believe it'll be got
library board you done know it's been
sensational I enjoyed it and I hope you
did too
take care some of the videos are
hilarious